la tecnología de la red de mensajeros se
basa la introducción de red en lugar de
una proteína para producir una respuesta
inmunitaria y esto es un tema que se
lleva estudiando desde hace años en
vacunas modernas llevaba una década
estudiando lo sutil y se ha puesto en
marcha desde el punto de vista de
utilización por primera vez en kobe sí y
esta polémica de las potentes ha rodeado
a las vacunas durante toda la pandemia
en casos como este en que la tecnología
es de interés general para la humanidad
no existe la posibilidad o capacidad
para que estas patentes sean abiertas
pese a su financiación privada al menos
en parte
bueno el debate en patentes es un debate
habitual en la industria farmacéutica la
razón por la que moderna está diciendo
que facer ha utilizado su patente son
dos razones una se puede utilizar la
tecnología rodrigo de aire en mensajero
pero moderna está diciendo que han
copiado elementos claves de la invención
que modern había puesto en marcha en
primer lugar una pequeña modificación
química que ellos hicieron a la rn
mensajero para evitar que produjera
inmunitaria no deseada él desaparece
mente moderna dice que hai será hecho
esa misma modificación y la segunda
moderna cuando puso en marcha una vacuna
para otra enfermedad merz otro
coronavirus moderna codificó todo lo que
es la proteína en espiga que tienen
estos coronavirus y la introdujo en un
amor en una partícula lipoproteína con
una bolita de protege de lipoproteína
esto mismo es lo que hizo en facer y
valiente y moderna dice que ellos
registraron la propiedad intelectual de
esa forma de formular y que sólo se
podría copiar tendrían libertad para ver
electo otras fórmulas formulaciones pero
moderna dice que estas dos formulaciones
pues corresponden a su propiedad
intelectual y como muy bien habéis
descrito moderna está diciendo no me
importa que lo comercial y 6 es los 92
países de recursos bajos y medios pero
esos 20 billones de ventas que tenéis
pues hablemos de ello porque no estáis
respetando mi propiedad intelectual
y brevemente una posible victoria de
moderna en este caso en que podría
afectar a las vacunas de fisher y bryant
tech desde el punto de vista del usuario
rodrigo no va a afectar en nada estas
patentes son muy habituales de hecho el
instituto nacional de salud americano de
luxe ya moderna por un tema de patente y
este litigios abierto otra compañía que
se llama curva ha denunciado a facer
también tras patentes son habituales y
son tema financiero la venta de vacunas
para facer de esta vacuna en concreto
han sido 20 millones de dólares moderna
10 millones de dólares entonces hay un
tema financiero un tema de intercambio
de beneficios entre compañías y desde el
punto de vista del ciudadano yo estaría
muy tranquila moderna ha dejado muy
claro que no va a poner en peligro la
comercialización de la vacuna esto es un
tema muy importante ni tampoco los
beneficios en países con pocos recursos
es un tema financiero rodrigo entre
compañías muy habitual y que va a llevar
años resolverse